die politik hat regelungen vorgegeben an
die sie sich selber mich hält das
robert-koch-institut hatte stufen pläne
entwickelt und da galt es auf einer
inzidenz zahl ab 50 über masken pflicht
nachzudenken beziehungsweise sie
anzuwenden
die kultusministerkonferenz stufen pläne
entwickelt an die sie sich selber nicht
hält und die gesundheits- und gaben
maßgaben diese zum teil aus überlastung
gründen selber nicht verfolgt können
sondern schulen werden schon beansprucht
damit auch kontakt verfolgung
nachzuvollziehen
also meine frage ist wir müssen die
regelung die bestehen tatsächlich
einhalten können und erwarte am montag
dass es eine stärkere verlässlichkeit
und klare regelung und ihre einhaltung
als botschaft von der kanzlerin und den
regierungs und den regierungschefs an
die einzelnen länder gibt ein großes
thema für viele institutionen in
deutschland sind die luftfilter geräte
die werden sehr hoch gelobt gibt es die
an deutschen schulen und gibt es
genügend davon ist auch wieder eine
frage an mich
wie genau ja genau es gibt keine
ausreichenden vorsorgemaßnahmen und die
luftfilter die luftfilter geräte gehören
dazu
es ist schon überaus erstaunlich dass
wir seit märz zeit dafür hatten
ausreichend masken fb2 maske lehrkräfte
zu besorgen dass es zeit war über solide
maßnahmen nachzudenken wenn man die
schulen offen halten will und dass wir
jetzt darüber redet darüber reden dass
das lüften ausreicht ohne entsprechende
luft reinigungsanlagen das zeigt dass
sich die politik zu wenig vorbereitet
hat auf das was schüler und lehrkräfte
täglich in den schulen erleben langer
rede kurzer sinn wir braucht die
anstrengungen der kommunen um luftfilter
anlagen neben vielen anderen maßnahmen
tatsächlich jetzt endlich einzuführen
die nächste frage an sie es gibt
wirklich viel kritik was die schulen
angeht das jetzt über den sommer nicht
genug getan wurde warum läuft alles so
schleppend das ist eine gute frage hat
das ist das was wir von anfang an
bemängelt haben dass wir gesagt haben
als sehr lockdown im märz kam mensch wir
müssen uns bewegen müssen schnelle
lösung finden es gab auch viele gute
ideen glaube ich wie man hätte vieles
anderes regeln können warum das in den
schubladen verschwunden ist
beziehungsweise warum das nicht
weiterbearbeitet wird zumindest
öffentlich nicht weiter bearbeitet wird
sodass wir nachvollziehen können dass
die kultusministerien dran arbeiten ist
für uns nicht nachvollziehbar waren ganz
früh dabei als bundeselternrat und hat
gesagt wir müssen über diese kleineren
märkten nachdenken
wir müssen darüber nachdenken wie wir
diese einzelnen maßnahmen umsetzen
können in den schulen werden
vorgeschlagen
außerschulische bildungsträger studenten
mit einzubinden
wir reden seit jahrzehnten davon dass
die sagen dass die idee gebe zustände an
den schulen eine katastrophe sind und
wenn man dann hört das nach vier fünf
monaten immer noch in den schulen
teilweise die hygiene schutzmaßnahmen
nicht umgesetzt sind ist das sehr sehr
traurig und
es gab vor den sommerferien und während
der sommerferien konzept gruppen in den
jeweiligen ländern wo stufen gehen
besprochen werden und die folgenden
kitzingen hat eben angesprochen da
wurden dann regelungen aufgestellt
interessanterweise auch wirklich
gemeinsam bearbeitet von eltern von
schülerinnen und schülern von
lehrkräften und von der politik warum
diese diese grenzen die wir dann
festgelegt haben die inzidenz zahlen
jetzt nicht umgesetzt werden und warum
wird uns daher nicht halten ist für uns
absolut nicht nachvollziehbar
und es ist keine vertrauensvolle und
ehrliche umgang miteinander das ist das
was wir deutlich kritisieren also auch
in diesem punkt wirklich große
fragezeichen auch frank schätzing ich
würde wieder zu ihnen kommen und zwar
möchte ich jetzt mit ihm mit ihnen über
den punkt digitalisierung sprechen hat
sich denn da etwas verbessert seit dem
frühjahr das ist ja wirklich noch mal
eine chance um weiter unterricht geben
zu können auch da ist es kein geheimnis
dass es einfach nicht funktioniert in
deutschland ja wir als deutscher
philologenverband am im märz bereits
like computer für alle schülerinnen und
schüler gefordert digitale endgeräte für
die lehrkräfte einen entsprechenden
support an den schulen
es gab auch etliche eltern initiativen
und firmen die sich an uns gewandt haben
die selber mit den schulen in kontakt
treten wollten wir haben gefordert dass
digitalisiert ware bildungsinhalte
besser zugänglich sind für lehrkräfte
und wir müssen jetzt einfach sagen dass
die anstrengungen der politik zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht
ausreichend waren und gegriffen haben
weil es in der tat immer noch nicht der
fall ist dass jede lehrkraft ein
digitales endgerät bekommen hat und dass
auch jeder schüler und jede schülerin
über ein entsprechendes endgerät
verfügen kann weil diese maßnahmen
einfach zu spät angeleiert worden sind
und zum jetzigen zeitpunkt bereits in
die praxis umgesetzt sein zu können
herr war es dann noch eine frage an sie
nach schätzungen sind ja 300.000 schüler
in quarantäne aktuell genaue zahlen über
kugel infizierungen gibt es aber nicht
die bildungsministerin hat in unserem
film gerade eben gesagt dass diese
zahlen vertretbar sind wie sehen sie das
und was fordern sie jetzt für die
nächsten monate also vertretbar sind die
zahlen aus meiner sicht nicht wir
anbauen lang mit frau karin schenk
drüber gesprochen ich glaube jeder
infizierte fall ist einer zuviel auch
die quarantäne ist als schutzmaßnahme zu
sehen aber wir haben ihnen wird dann
muss entsprechend im ausgleich
stattfinden damit keine
bildungsungerechtigkeit aufkommen
das heißt die schule schülerinnen und
schüler die zu hause sind wie nicht
hingehen können in die schule weil eben
quarantäne angeordnet ist dann müssen
die eine andere art der beschädigung
erfahren entweder im rahmen vom hybrid
unterricht oder sonstigen möglichkeiten
da gibt es vielfältige ansätze für es
ist uns klar gewesen dass wir natürlich
auch die digitalisierung die wir
verschlafen haben in den letzten nicht
in den letzten monaten der pandemie
sondern in den letzten jahrzehnten wenn
die skandinavischen länder gucken da
reden wir seit dem jahr 2000 davon dass
digitalisierung in den schulen
funktioniert wir müssen vor allem in die
infrastruktur aufbauen das heißt wir
brauchen überall wähler haben sie kennen
selber wenn es unterwegs sind in
deutschland haben sich immer wieder
diese sogenannten follower oder wir
haben keinen wlan in den schulen nicht
die bandbreiten die wir benötigen das
war klar
die geräte zu beschaffen das ist glaube
ich nicht das große problem gewesen aber
auch hier zeigt sich instrument deutlich
wer stattet diese geräte aus das heißt
das für apps kommt drauf welche
programme ist der datenschutz
gewährleistet
das ist alles offene fragen und diese
zeit müssen wir jetzt ganz dringend
nutzen dass wir für den weiteren doktor
und falls er kommen sollte was ich nicht
hoffe denn wir wollen auch gerne
präsenzunterricht beibehalten aber immer
unter den krieg der gesundheitsvorsorge
da müssen wir uns aber darauf
vorbereiten dass wir da eben nicht
hängen bleiben und dass es nicht zu
weiteren bildungs ungerechtigkeiten für
unsere schülerinnen und schüler kommt
denn der jetzigen schüler generation
haben wir schon sehr viel zu geübt was
so nicht weitergehen kann bildung unsere
primäre sowie wir haben in deutschland
und dann müssen wir auch fest an heisst
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren